to get to abba we drove through the  night  the chinese government says foreign  journalists are free to visit the town  but the reality is this remote tibetan  region is under  lockdown we managed to slip past the  police checkpoints at dawn  the chinese authorities say they're  preparing for war against tibetan  saboteurs  but there's no sign of any fighting in  abba  just the intimidating presence of  china's state security forces  ranks of riot police crouch behind steel  barricades  to avoid detection we filmed  surreptitiously these are rare pictures  of china's tense relationship with its  tibetan people  the heart of abba is kirti monastery a  center of buddhist learning for five  centuries  the tibetan faithful are still drawn  here prostrating themselves in worship  sending their children to join the  monastic order  200 yards away chinese paramilitary  police have swamped the town  it's an impressive show of force but  it's not clear why it's necessary  the only violence